many lawmakers got their first chance to
visit one of the Border Patrol detention
facilities this weekend Democratic
senator Elizabeth Warren toward a facili
facility in McAllen Texas yesterday and
described what she saw it's a disturbing
picture there are children by themselves
I saw six-month-old baby little girls
little boys the government says more
than 500 immigrant children are back
with their families more than two
thousand others are still in shelters
David Pegg now is at a detention
facility in Port Isabel Texas near the
border where some reunifications are
supposed to be taking place David good
morning John good morning supposed to be
as the operative word there we're
essentially having to take the
government's word for it we've gotten no
pictures no video and no opportunity to
actually witness one of those
reunifications Port Isabel here is
literally in the middle of nowhere we're
not very far from the Mexican border and
really close to the Gulf of Mexico this
is where the government says they're
going to do reunifications they're going
to take kids reunite them with their
parents this is also the facility where
Elizabeth Warren and others toured over
the weekend one congresswoman from
Florida described it as a jail that may
not surprise you it's a detention
facility but the same congresswoman said
she met with about 20 women who all said
they were separated from their kids and
all of those women are wondering where
their kids have been taken since the
separation about an hour west of here
over the weekend senator Warren and
other legislators also toured the
McAllen processing facility that's the
spot that we've shown you over the last
week those pictures of people being kept
in locked cages well Senator Warren and
the others had a chance to see babies
some as young as newborns also over the
weekend there was a protest where
activists actually stopped a bus that
was leaving the facility by the way we
followed one of those buses it appears
they go in two places either to the bus
station downtown where people are
released and given a summons to appear
before a judge or Gail they're either
going to federal court to appear before
a judge bottom line this morning we need
more details as to where when and
whether or not we can document these
reunifications
and that's why it's good you're there
David
bag no the world is watching they must
figure this out thank you very much